Репер на найбільшому звалищі електронних відходів світу в Гані.
Німецький вчитель Ян Камманн із Гамбурга доїхав аж сюди і зробив це відео.
Один з його учнів походить з Гани і підказав йому це місце.
У дев’ятому класі діти вивчають географію та торгівлю.
Тому я відвідав у Аккрі, столиці Гани, одне дуже особливе місце,
так зване "токсичне місто" або Аґбоґблоші, якщо казати точніше.
Там розбирають старі електроприлади.
Вчитель географії та англійської викладає в одній з гімназій Гамбурга учням з усього світу.
Щоб краще їх зрозуміти, він рік подорожував країнами їхнього походження.
Ян Камманн часто почувався безпорадним під час подорожей.
Так само, як почуваються учні, які приходять в його клас - часто не знаючи німецької мови.
Завдяки цій поїздці я тепер знаю, яке це відчуття.
Не могти щось сказати. Я стикався з цим дуже часто.
Ян Камманн відвідав 14 країн - від Південної Америки до Азії. Так він став ближчим своїм учням.
Коли він написав книгу і запросив нас на презентацію, ми дуже пишалися ним.
Особливо коли ми прочитали про нього в газеті, ми поширили статтю в соціальних мережах.
Ми дуже пишаємося тим, що пан Камманн викладає в нашій школі і є нашим учителем.
Перед тим як вирушити в подорож,
школярі склали своєму вчителеві 40 власноруч зроблених путівників.
У них - чимало корисної інформації.
Це основи.
Завдяки путівникам Ян Камманн познайомився у різних країнах з багатьма людьми.
Деякі путівники не лише корисні, але й з гумором.
"Якщо хочете більше інформації…Будь-ласка… гугліть"